ننتقل لموضوع اخر طيران لانه فيها او فيما
كانت لا تزال في طريقها الى الهبوط راكب
فتح باب الطائره في السماء واثار رعب
المسافرين كلكم شفتوا الفيديو بعتقد
الطائره التابعه لشركه
جيانا ايرلاين هبطت بسلام في مدينه ديغو
الكوريه الجنوبيه بعدما فتح الراكب بابها
في الجو قبل وقت قصير من الهبوط على مدرج
المطار
لانه مسؤول في سي ان مشاهدينا قال انه
طائره كانت على بعد دقيقتين الى ثلاث
دقائق تقريبا من الهبوط وكانت على ارتفاع
700 قدم فوق الارض عندما فتح رجل في
الثلاثينيات من عمره كان جالسا في مقعد
الطوارئ فتح الباب فيما ذكرت الشرطه
المحليه انه تم القبض على الرجل عند وصوله
والتحقيق قائم معه بتهمه انتهاك قانون
الطيران يمكن ان يحاكم
ويحكم عليه بالسجنه لمده تصل الى عشر
سنوات طبعا لو فتح الباب لو فتح الباب
يعني قبل واحنا في وسط الرحله لكان لا سمح
الله طائره كلها سقطت لطف الله كان انها
انها كانت قريبه من الارض
تصريحات يقولون بانه هو يقول بانه يخشى من
الاماكن المغلقه لكن ما يطلع لها
هو عشان يرتاح ممكن اقعد عشر سنين بالسجن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات